So one of the most common questions I get asked
is my advice to high school girls
who want to be traditional wives in the future.
So first of all,
you may or may not be super supported in this idea,
and that is okay
coming from me.
I was not super supported in my decision
to drop out of college and become a traditional wife.
But I will tell you this,
your family members and your friends
usually come around,
and if they don't,
that's okay.
You are supposed to be happy in life,
and being happy is gonna look different for everybody.
To go to college or not is a personal decision.
So think wisely about what you really want to do.
Don't feel pressured to go to college.
Don't feel pressured not to go to college.
It's okay to take a gap year.
Take a step back.
You just graduated high school.
You've probably been in public school your entire life,
since you were five.
And it's okay to just
take a breather and figure out what you want to do.
Personally, I was homeschooled in high school.
And after I was done with high school,
I took a gap year
and I got a part time job at a supplement store.
And that is where I Learned a lot about nutrition
and supplements.
And I had a lot of fun with it.
And then I went to college.
I went to community college a year later.
I highly recommend community college.
I would recommend that over university any day,
especially because your first two years
are very important
and you don't want to go back and forth
when it comes to changing your major.
When you go to a university,
you have to pick a particular major,
whereas in community college
you have more broad majors to choose from,
so it's a lot less stress
when it comes to picking your courses and your major.
Community college also gives you
the chance to stay home with your family,
which I think is so important.
If you have a very loving,
supporting family that wants the best for you,
stay at home.
I don't know what this whole rush is to
to get out of home.
And you know,
you see 18 year old girls
getting apartments together
and working full time
just to pay for those apartments
and it's silly.
If you don't need to leave the home,
then don't leave your home.
On a serious note,
that is my number one tip
for young girls wanting to be traditional wives.
Do not leave home
unless you absolutely need to
or you don't have a healthy dynamic at home.
Stay home as long as you possibly can.
Contribute around the house, do chores.
Contributing around the house
also will teach you home making skills.
Learn to cook.
Practice recipes in your family's kitchen
and feed your family delicious food
and new recipes you've tried.
Clean the House,
help your mom out if you can
and learn different cleaning techniques
if you would like to get a part time job.
This is so much fun to experiment.
And usually
these part time jobs are nothing super serious,
they're just to get you out in the world
in the working world
and give you some experience,
especially like
customer service experience. Again,
I worked at a supplement store
and I was homeschooled for high school,
so I became really shy and introverted.
And I think getting into that supplement store
and learning customer service skills
and learning how to speak to people
and help people
really helped me
because in the beginning it was.
It was hard.
Like I would just laugh awkwardly
when I didn't know what to do.
And I think
the longer I worked at that store,
the better I became at communicating with people.
One of the biggest pros to staying home,
having a part time job
or going to community college
is that you
kind of still get to be like a kid and.
And to feel like a kid.
You're dependent on your family
and you're still safe at home,
but you're able to
take that next step into the big world,
which is getting a job
and just having that experience
and being able to spend money.
You learn to spend money a little bit more wisely
and you learn how to save up for things
rather than just
asking your Mom or dad
for money to get things,
you have to learn.
Okay, well, this paycheck,
I can get this,
and then maybe
the next paycheck,
I can get that.
I want to add,
you don't need to go to college.
You shouldn't feel pressured to.
If you want to be a traditional wife in the future,
you don't need to go to college.
This narrative that
women who don't go to college
or people in general
who don't go to college
are uneducated
is so false.
We have the internet,
we have books.
We have so many resources
at our fingertips.
You don't need
to go to college to get educated.
In fact, you will save yourself so much money
if you do decide
not to go to college
or if you just go to community college
for your associates.
Other tip is to get involved in something
extracurricular
if you want to be a traditional wife.
Part of being a traditional wife
is that you are serving your family,
and you are serving others
that you love.
And a great way to practice this
is to get involved in something
that doesn't pay you.
So volunteering
so you can get involved in
your local church,
the church that maybe
you've grown up going to,
and you can help with the children center.
This is a great way to get
also to get involved with children
and learn how to care for them.
So those are just some tips.
For younger girls
who want to be traditional wives in the future,
remember, the best tip I can give you
is to involve yourself in things
that are going to better
you as a wife
and a mother
in the future
and better you as a homemaker
in general. So
I hope these tips helped you guys,
and best of luck to you
younger ladies.